>>> FROM BASEBALL TICKETS TO HOT
DOGS AND A SHOT AT A MILLION
DOLLARS, STATES AND BUSINESSES
ARE GOING ALL OUT TO URGE PEOPLE
TO GET THE COVID VACCINE.
THE PACE OF NEW VACCINATIONS HAS
SLOWED IN THE U.S. TO ABOUT 1.8
MILLION SHOTS A DAY.
THAT IS DOWN MORE THAN -- FROM
MORE THAN THREE MILLION A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
RIGHT NOW ABOUT 59% OF ADULTS
HAVE HAD AT LEAST ONE SHOT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HOPES THAT
NUMBER WILL RISE TO 70% BY THE
FOURTH OF JULY.
SO TO SEE HOW BUSINESSES ARE
HELPING HIM MEET THAT GOAL, I
TOOK A TRIP AROUND NEW YORK CITY
AND LEARNED WHAT YOUR COVID SHOT
CAN GET YOU FOR FREE.
>> AND CRACKS ONE DOWN THE RIGHT
FIELD LINE --
>> HOW ABOUT A FREE DAY AT THE
BALLPARK?
>> THE DIVE AND HE MADE THE
CATCH!
>> I THOUGHT THIS WAS A CIVIC
DUTY TO TRY AND DO WHAT WE COULD
TO SUPPORT THE VACCINATION
PROGRAM.
SO IF THEY GET VACCINATED ON
SITE, THEY'LL GET TWO FREE
TICKETS EITHER FOR THAT NIGHT'S
GAME OR A LATER GAME.
♪
>> HE STRUCK IT OUT, THE BALL
GAME IS OVER.
>> BUSINESSES ARE OFFERING
INCENTIVES IF YOU SHOW YOUR
VACCINATION CARD.
I'M HERE AT KRISPI KREME.
THEY ARE OFFERING ONE FREE
ORIGINAL GLAZED DOUGHNUT IF YOU
SHOW THIS.
IF YOU DO NOT KNOW, NOW YOU
KNOW.
IF YOU DOUGH-NUT NOW, NOW YOU
I DIDN'T WRITE THAT.
NICE.
YEAH.
BEING VACCINATED NEVER TASTED SO
GOOD.
YOU CAN ESSENTIALLY SPEND YOUR
ENTIRE DAY GETTING FREE STUFF
ALL ACROSS THE CITY.
AT VITAMIN SHOPPE THEY'RE
OFFERING FREE SNACKS, FREE
BEVERAGES, SOMETHING HEALTHY IF
YOU SHOW YOUR VACCINATION CARD.
>> WE'RE A HEALTH AND WELLNESS
COMPANY AND BELIEVE THAT
EVERYONE DESERVES GOOD HEALTH
AND WANT TO PLAY WHATEVER PART
WE CAN IN THAT.
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A GREAT
WAY TO JUST GIVE PEOPLE A
HEALTHY SNACK AND DRINK.
>> ZERO SUGAR.
IT WAS VITA-MINT TO BE.
RIGHT HERE AT THE AMERICAN
MUSEUM OF NATURAL HISTORY, YOU
CAN GET ONE OF THESE.
A MUSEUM VOUCHER.
IT OFFERS FOUR FREE
COMPLEMENTARY TICKETS TO THE
MUSEUM.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THE VACCINE
PROGRAM INCLUDING, I GUESS, THE
WHALE.
WE'VE COME ACROSS THE EAST RIVER
TO BROOKLYN, NEW YORK, THE HOME
OF NATHAN'S FAMOUS FRANKFURTERS.
ON THE DAY THAT YOU ARE
VACCINATED, IF YOU BRING YOUR
VACCINE CARD TO NATHAN'S, YOU
WILL GET A FREE HOT DOG.
LET'S BE FRANK, YOU KNOW I GOT
TO DO THAT.
ZERO DOLLARS.
I LIKE THAT.
TIME FOR DESSERT.
AT JUNIOR'S CHEESECAKE, WE'RE
GOING TO TALK TO ALAN ROSEN.
HE IS THE THIRD GENERATION
OWNER/PROPRIETOR OF THIS
ESTABLISHMENT AT THIS LOCATION.
HE'S GOING TO TELL US WHAT HE'S
DOING TO STEP UP.
>> YOU COME IN WITH YOUR
VACCINATION CARD THAT WE'RE
CARRYING AROUND, YOU SHOW IT TO
THE CASHIER, THEY GIVE YOU AN
INDIVIDUAL CHEESECAKE.
SIMPLE AS THAT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PIECE OF CAKE.
GET VACCINATED.
HOW CAN YOU LOSE?
>> I KNOW.
ALAN SENT A NOTE -- THANK YOU,
"DEAR GAYLE, THANK YOU FOR
SPREADING THE WORD."
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, ALAN.
>> SO THAT IS --
>> THANKS FOR THE FREE SAMPLES.
>> YES!
>> THESE ARE LITTLE CHEESE CAKES
THAT YOU GET WHEN YOU GO INTO
JUNIOR'S CHEESECAKE.
OF COURSE KRISPI KREME --
>> YES --
>> SO DELICIOUS.
WE MISSED ONE.
>> THIS IS MY HEROIN RIGHT HERE.
RIGHT HERE.
THIS IS MY SECOND DAY OF A FAST,
AND I'M READY TO EAT ANTHONY'S
GLSSES AND PRETEND THEY'RE
POTATO CHIPS.
I'M SO HUNGRY.
THIS WAS GREAT, THOUGH.
>> THERE'S A NEW ONE -- SHAKE